please
[Applause]
you're
so beautiful
my goodness
thank you oh you're so beautiful
and you're so
incredibly talented i have loved you in
so many different incredible
iterations and films and god you've
really tackled zombies and
pirates and um
you know now now this um
we've actually been talking about all
things earth and you're in the man who
fell to earth which is the classic david
bowie film if he's not the sexiest man
that ever lived i don't know who is and
so talented he's amazing in that film
it's like his his uh film debut and he's
incredible in that movie everything he
did
he turned into gold he's the most
magnanimous man so i love that this film
is not a remake it's like a
leave off and
move forward which is so interesting to
five years after the original film was
made it's just there's no rules we can
get so creative in the film world or
television world with storytelling and i
love that this film picks up where it
left off and you're doing it with um
chuatel edgy of four who is just such an
amazing actor phenomenal and nominated
as well for academy awards
um
but is it true that you guys used to
date in real oh my gosh this is your
first question to me drew
um yeah i never ever talk about my
private life i have to say that but your
research i have to say she is incredible
because we've been doing so much press
and nobody else has spotted this nobody
else yeah except your show and you're an
amazing researcher
yeah we were in our 20s it was a long
time ago i feel like i revisited a few
exes in the last few years like
kind of as friends like where are we at
now
um i also was like it was my fault
everything was my fault and i will
revisit them and i'm like oh you're
still doing that thing too okay
interesting great maybe it was 50 50.
cool
yeah well it definitely wasn't like that
with churrotar i mean like we were so
young and it was
really a brief kind of thing and we were
mainly just friends to be honest and uh
and then we saw each other again um
making this and we've stayed in contact
since and you know it was really easy
and fun and there were no awkward
moments whatsoever i like working with
access i liked like tom green came on
this show i i think it's fun you're
probably like where is this all going i
came on the show and here i am bringing
out the x-files um but i'm i i'm very
excited for this project
[Music]